welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
Season 2 trailer for HBO's House of the
Dragon a prequel series set about 200
years before the events of the Game of
Thrones the series follows the Targaryen
Dynasty during the dance of the Dragons
the Targaryen Civil War recounted in
George AR Martin's novel Fire and Blood
season two will pick up after the boys
fight over Storm's end that ended season
one with Prince aund on his dragon vagar
champen lucer and his Dragon RX luceros
being the Second Son of rera who's now
pissed and ready to strike back against
the Green faction and aliceon I'm going
to break down this trailer for what to
expect when this show returns in 2024
and just to give everyone a reminder of
all the family drama and the factions
because yeah it has been over a year and
everyone's names sound the same but
before we begin with this to anyone who
watches this show but has not read the
book Fire and Blood and doesn't know
what's coming from now on on this
channel all speculation based on events
in the book that have not yet transpired
on the show I'm going to be moving to
the ends of any videos we do on House of
the Dragon I should have been doing that
before I'm really sorry that I didn't I
I thought I Could Be Clever with how I
worded things to like wink book readers
without tipping everyone else off but I
wasn't very good at it so from now on
just to play it safe I'm going to
introduce the spoiler dungeon to give
people the option to skip the book based
speculation at the end of the video if
they want to but for any like blind
theories that have nothing to do with
further book knowledge really just a
based on the show or history that was
already talked about in episodes of Game
of Thrones I think that's all still fair
game but I am still going to just do my
best to make sure everyone's getting the
most out of these breakdowns okay season
one dash through the history of the
targaryan family tree with Patty kadine
as vizer the first a king chosen by his
grandfather jeris at the Council of 101
at heren Hall chosen over rise the queen
Who Never Was theer Weds Emma Aaron who
gives him rira but she dies in
childbirth with their son Balon this
sets up a succession concern between
rira and vas's brother Damon Matt Smith
AG grieving vieras gets close to rira's
childhood friend Allison Hightower
daughter of the hand of the king otoh
high tower in Allison and vieras Mary
which is a betrayal to rira and sets up
otoh high tower as kind of a pushy
creepy tactician meanwhile everyone in
the show is inappropriate rira and her
Uncle Damon have a really gross
relationship rira also hooks up with sir
Christen Cole her protector in the
King's Guard but she declines his
proposal to alope with her and she
instead agrees to be wed to S Leonor
valaran a family of Dragon Riders from
drift Mark and the son of Reise and
Corless valaran leor is secretly gay but
reera and he have an understanding Uncle
Damon meanwhile is married off to Lady
Rhea Roy of the veil but he murders her
In Cold Blood then he marries Lor's
sister lady Le bearing daughters baa and
Raina horana ends up undergoing an
agonizing labor and she commands her
Dragon vagar to incinerate her meanwhile
rira has given birth to Three Sons jeris
or Jace lucerys or Luke and newborn
Joffrey but since it's kind of an Open
Secret that Lenor is gay and the fact
that none of these boys have Platinum
Valyrian hair this starts the rumor that
they were actually the bastard children
of Sir Harwin strong which yeah they are
so we got Damon still with Baya and
Raina alicent meanwhile has given birth
to a son aegon and a second son Aon and
a daughter Helena who's a bug girl all
of these families gather at drift Mark
for L's funeral where aan a young boy
seeking a dragon hijacks the late lady
Lana's Dragon of vagar for a night
flight pissing off Lana's daughters Baya
and Raina as well as Luke and Jace aan
insults Luke and Jace calling them
bastards and Luke slashes out aiman's
eye Allison aon's mother is pissed and
she lunges at Luke with the Valyrian
steel dagger the two future Queens face
off with each other creating a divide in
the family and Rea and her Uncle Demon
Mary in the old custom on Dragon Stone
and set up home there while rira's
previous husband of Leonor is thought to
be dead but the show actually takes the
step of revealing that he's still alive
Lord corus's Brother vyond appeals to uh
getting up there theer to be named Lord
of drift Mark and calls rira a and
her son's bastards in front of the whole
court and Damon beheads him theer this
episode finally dies and Allison hears
him uttering among his final words his
fears of Egon the conqueror's dream
which he had shared with the younger
rira in the very first episode aing to
the Conqueror who had this dream to
unite all of westos against an
apocalyptic threat from the north and
this dream will go on to Doom his family
lineage as Allison hears the word aegon
and assumes that vieras wants her son
aegon to be named this is why it's a
problem that everyone's name sound alike
that's an intentional Choice by George R
Martin it leads to all this confusion so
they end up crowning aegon in the dragon
pit and rise on her Dragon Mell
interrupts a ceremony bursting out of
the ground killing thousands and rather
than ending the war right there by just
torching the she decides and she flees
to Dragon Stone and this news causes
rira to go through a lot of stress and
she delivers a premature still birth Sir
Eric not sir aric I know I know delivers
vas's Crown to rera and Damon crowns her
there on Dragon Stone so we have two
factions we have the greens that's the
high Towers through Queen Allison her
father OT high tower Allison's son King
Egon and King's always in quotation
marks at this point in history as well
as Allison Second Son Prince aund and
her daughter bug girl Prince Elena they
have a fourth kid Daron whom we have not
seen yet on the show he's in Oldtown
Allison's creepy foot fishous Lackey
Lord Laris strong who killed off his
father in herin Hall so that Allison's
Dad could be hand to the King again this
is by the way Carwin's brother the true
biological father of jce luk and Joffrey
so the greens are all in King's Landing
also through aan they have one of the
largest dragons vagar and also loyal to
Allison is Sir Kristen Cole and then the
other faction are the blacks this
include rira her husband Uncle Damon
Rene's sons of Jace Luke and Joffrey
Damon's Daughters of baa and Raina Reise
in house valaran and a lot of other
dragons they're just smaller they're
housed at Dragon Stone the season
culminates as rira sends Reise and her
sons Jason Luke to recruit houses Aaron
Stark and Baratheon as allies to the
blacks young Luke goes to Storm's in to
appeal to boros Baratheon but he finds
Prince aan already there making a better
promise to Lord Baratheon Luke leaves on
arax through the storm but aund pursues
him on vagar to scare him but the
dragons end up defying their Riders and
attack each other anyway vear eats RX
and Luke rira gets the news and it's is
pissed and before we get into news for
season 2 a bit of hot guys from Boss
season 1 showrunner and director Miguel
spotnik best known for directing the
episodes like the Battle of Winterfell
and hard home from Game of Thrones and
the episodes of season 1 he is not
returning for season 2 and as is
Apparently after HBO refused to let his
wife Alexis Raven be a producer Raven
was a producer in season 1 and she
appeared in season one as Alice's made
Talia which you know just kind of make
of that what you will head Rider Ryan
condo will be the sole showrunner of
this series now hopefully the new
directors they get to shoot these
episodes will do a better job with day
for night shooting and not blame our TV
settings so the new footage opens with
rira looking out over storms in over
shipbreaker Bay the storm is cleared for
now but she's surveying this crime scene
after Aid and vag's attack on lucer and
RX now in the Fire and Blood text
according to mushrooms account Lucas's
remains are later discovered to have
been mutilated after the fact to remove
both his eyes implying that aan found
the body and stabbed him in the eyes and
there are examples on the HBO series of
the show confirming mushrooms accounts
to be canon in some way ways like Rene's
night out with dam in the street of silk
but the Dragon Battle in season 1 showed
both these guys begging their dragons to
stop fighting and I just don't think the
show version of Amen would do this we
hear Auto high tower admitting errors
were made in the hours following King
V's death yeah and that's the
understatement of the Year Aon the
second of the green faction ascends to
the iron throne and he's even wearing
green with two golden dragons emblazoned
over it we see encampments of Team black
and Team Green the banners of house high
tower on the March this could be
Christen CO's to rook's rest talk about
that later we see some close-ups of the
shields of house roseby that's one with
the three red stripes as well as house
stokeworth that's the Lamb with a Golden
Goblet on the field of green both of
these houses are loyal to rira in the
black faction sir Kristen Cole I think
that is the King's Guard loyal to the
greens beheads a lord who's wearing red
and black looks like one of many
different rira supporting Lords who the
greens will be executing at the small
Council table I love this detail the
marble ball that belongs to King Aon II
spins around his plate but refuses to
settle in in its place these attendance
plates were a new detail added to the
HBO series and think about it since all
these characters claims to the throne
are tenuous and limited within this
interf family Civil War I just like the
symbolism of aegon's attendance fall
refusing to get comfortable in its place
thank you to geology for partnering with
us to bring you this video and also for
giving our audiences exclusive access to
their new try before you bu program
you've probably heard me mentioned
geology before the 28 time award-winning
skin hair and body care company
recognized IM men's hype Beast bird
Esquire askmen and Oprah daily grooming
Awards but hey I get it it can be tough
to change a skincare routine or start a
new one part of what's nice about giy is
they create simple and effective
skincare and Hair Care routines
customized just for you and now if you
want to try that new routine out before
you buy a bunch of stuff you can gey is
offering new Rockstar viewers a free
trial of their eight-piece skincare set
with their try before you buy program
you can experience a new skincare
routine risk-free for 14 days if you
don't love it send it back it's that
easy the set is valued at $139 all you
pay today is the price of shipping and
if you order today get a free vitamin C
plus e fuic acid as a gift you don't
need to return it that's yours just head
to geology.com neww rockstars and get
your free trial and geology will send
you a personalized skincare routine and
if you don't mind me I'm going to take
some geology and uh uh look good for the
rest of this video aegon is wearing the
crown of aegon the Conqueror his
namesake that's black has the red ruby
in the center whereas riro wears the
crown of vieras her father the one that
previously was worn by J at the Council
of 101 and I like how renea's new dress
has two dragon heads on her shoulders
looks amazing now a quick shot of a
silvercolor dragon flying above this new
character the dragon could be sea smoke
that was the dragon of lanor and that
might make this character Adam of H So
Adam is believed to be played by actor
Clinton Liberty Adam's brother Allan of
Hall is played by the actor Abu bakar
Sim So Adam and Allan are Dragon Seed
who claim to be the bastard son of
Leonor valaran but or actually rumored
to be the bastard of corus in Fire and
Blood Dragon seeds are recruited by team
black to ride some unclaimed dragons
because there's just like a ton of
dragons on Dragon Stone that's what we
saw Damon doing at the end of season one
just trying to tame some more dragons
that are within this layer and the
dragon scene Adam ends up mounting sea
smoke but the weird thing is about the
show is lanor in the show is not dead
he's still alive so we're going to see
what happens with sea smoke if he'll
still have that link to leor the other
Dragon seeds in Fire and Blood include
Hugh Hammer who's a really fun character
ol the white who is going to be played
in the show by Tom Bennett Nettles who's
also a really cool character in silver
Dennis Reise tells rira there's no war
so hateful to the gods as a war between
kin and no war so bloody as a war
between dragons and aan walks up to the
empty Iron Throne as thunder and
lightning strike outside he seems to be
haunted by the storm in which vagar
killed Luke like everywhere he goes he's
going to feel the rumbling of storms in
following him they like Charlie Brown
with a raincloud over his head in fact
the death of luceros will give aen the
nickname of kinslayer and it's something
that Otto and Allison will shame him for
structurally on this HBO series I wonder
if he's going to be kind of like a Jamie
Lannister character someone who's
clearly an ass hole but an that
we all just kind of like also he's got
an eye patch we see a group heading
north through the snow and I'm pretty
sure this is jerus Jace making his case
to the Starks and we are going to meet
Lord krian Stark played by Tom Taylor
and yeah we're probably going to see
Winterfell on the show that's going to
be fun rir meets with someone else on
this Sand Dune two dragons two figures
facing off on the left that's definitely
Cyrax re's Golden Dragon and then on the
right that might be sea smoke which
could be leanor in this moment
relinquishing sea smoke to her or it
could be one of the Dragon seeds who is
now claiming the dragon we get this
overhead shot of Helena bug girl and I
promise I'm going to stop making fun of
her for the bug girl stuff I only bring
it up because season one hinted that she
is a way more interesting character than
you'd gather from reading the text like
she seems to be a dreamer like her
ancestor Denise dreamer whose dream
convinced her father to relocate the
whole family from valyria to Dragon
Stone and escape the Doom of valyria and
the same kind of dreaming tradition that
affected aegon the Conqueror whose dream
led him to Westeros many of the things
Helena mumbled in season 1 under her
breath ended up coming true for her
family like they'll have to close one
eye setting up aim and one eye and in
particular she loves insects and spiders
spiders being symbols of fate and have
just led many of us to think that she
could also have green Seer blood from
the first men now while Damon's
daughters baa and Renna don't really do
that much in the text during the war we
do see a shot of baa here on Dragon back
writing her Dragon Moon Dancer kind of
screaming like her mother lyanna did
when we saw her in season 1 meanwhile
her sister Ranna hasn't bonded with a
dragon yet as of season 1 episode 10 but
we'll see in this second season quick
shot of a soldier from house Bracken
drawing his sword you can tell from the
red stallion on the gold field remember
season one included that duel between
the young William Blackwood and the
bully he stabbed to death Jerell Bracken
at Storm's end for riner's hand and
fireing blood was actually kind of the
reverse with different character names
like Lord Samuel Blackwood defeated sir
Amos Bracken George R Martin loves to do
this like name characters with similarly
sounding names intentionally and the
show did the switch I think to suggest
that the HBO depiction of events can
twist history on a dime the show has not
wanted us to to forget about these two
families in season 1 episode 6 the small
Council brings up the land dispute where
house Bracken Annex land from house
Blackwood in episode 9 we learn of house
brackens swearing allegiance to Egon II
so this feud between the blackwoods and
the brackens goes way back and it's
going to turn an ugly head during the
Civil War so don't sleep on it there's a
quick shot of Helena being grabbed with
a knife to her throat yes this is part
of the blood and cheese moment I'm going
to get to that more in the spoiler
dungeon as I will this shot of Sir Eric
Cargill or maybe his twin brother sir
aric Cargill swinging a sword in a bed
chamber probably locking swords with
their brother in season one Eric helped
reira Escape King's Landing and brought
her VI's Crown Eric's brother sir aric
remains loyal to Allison and eggon the
second and yeah the confusion over their
names and their twin likenesses isn't an
accident we'll talk about it later the
trailer ends with these three rapid
succession battle shots aund on Dragon
back ring vagar reira on Dragon back on
CX I think from a different scene and
then aiman's massive dragon vagar flying
overhead the glory shot of this trailer
P struck in its aged wings and while
it's meant to show off their VFX power
at HBO The edit of this shot is so weird
like we don't see where the dragon is
going and it just cuts at this random
shot and it really just seems like
they're trying to obscure what he is
flying toward who else is in this battle
and where it is but I think we are
seeing the Battle of rook's rest but
before I get to spoiler dungeon to go
into that my favorite thing about House
of the dragon and fire and blood is the
way this story is compiled from
unreliable narrators Witnesses with the
only part of the story notice how some
of the more pointed conversations in
this HBO series occur when the
characters are private quarters till the
maesters leave the room and then
suddenly they start talking about dreams
and visions and dark motivations and
things that one character know that the
other character doesn't know yet we have
not seen Mushroom on the series and my
theory is that the salacious gossiper of
mushroom is meant to be us the viewers
the social media fandom the salacious
bloodthirsty masses who tune into these
HBO series at our own Peril as we want
blood and horrific violence and then we
go online and we fill the gaps in the
historical record with the most exciting
head Cannon we could think of and this
gives the show more room to add some
more interesting inner thoughts and
motivations from these characters that
the MERS who wrote Fire and Blood would
not know about because they weren't
there to see okay so quickly let's go
into spoiler dungeon this is for book
readers and then I guess for people who
just don't care either way blood and
cheese so in season 1 we met mazaria the
Spy master who in firing blood Damon
orders to hire two assassins to sneak
into the red keep there's blood who had
served under Damon in the king's watch
previously and cheese a rat catcher who
knows several passageways in and out of
the red key we saw young rera sneak out
of one of these passage ways on her big
night out in season 1 and there were
some Curious close-ups of rats
throughout the red keep throughout
season 1 and I'm pretty sure that's
setting up this big red wedding size
moment in season 2 so blood and cheese
on Damon's orders sneak into the red key
bind and gag Allison and take Helena by
a knife and tell her that they're there
to take a son for her son and they tell
her which of her two sons that she had
with aegon II to spare and which to kill
and Helena says take me and they're like
no it has to be a son and she goes okay
then the younger son mord but then blood
BL instead beheads the other son the
older one jarris this is going to send
Helena into a deep depression and
obviously just escalates everything and
they order all the rat catchers and
King's Landing to be killed so the place
just gets infested with rats and then
they just got to bring in a ton of cats
but I hope on the show this isn't the
end of the character Helena because if
they are making her a dreamer or a green
saer maybe there's some other fate for
her Beyond this and I think this Blood
and- cheese moment is coming soon folks
because there's only going to be eight
episodes of the season and Rumor Has It
episode 2 is going to include the battle
of the Cargill Brothers Sir Eric versus
sir aric when sir aric sneaks into a
dragon Stone disguised as his twin
brother Sir Eric and the two end up in a
duel and then dying each other's arms
because they love each other in Fire and
Blood Grandmaster monin says that AR's
mission was to kill rira and end the
Rebellion but mushroom says it was to
kill rira's bastard Sons Jace and Joff
in retaliation of what happened to
Helena and Jaris so where is the season
headed based on the scale of the battle
and the way rise is framed in this
trailer with a big line about Gods
punishing battles among kin I think the
big climax of season 2 is going to be
Rooks r rest sir Christen Cole marches
the greens to rook's rest in the
crownlands and Reise flies out with
melly's to help Lord Stanton Aon II
shows up on Sunfire aan shows up on
vagar the three dragons fight it in the
air they become entangled Reise dies
burnt to an unrecognizable degree melees
dies aegon suffers severe burns and
Sunfire is rendered flightless so while
King aegon is incapacitated aund steps
up as Regent and protector of the realm
this would be a major realignment to end
the season on and I just think they the
budget for like one major Dragon Battle
per season these Eight Episodes are
coming summer 2024 this is one of the
last videos I'm shooting before I
officially leave for my paternity leave
I pre-taped a lot of fun videos that you
are really going to enjoy so you'll
still see me on this channel like twice
a week or so Jessica Clemens and others
on this channel are covering for me
while I'm out and thank you so much to
everyone for your well wishes follow me
at eaos follow new rockstars And
subscribe to new rock stars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching
bye
[Music]
la